notre monde c'est squeeze oui c'était là
coup d'édition aujourd'hui on est sur
noir mâle adventures c'est la suite de
strange adventures ces partis start pour
faire semblant que ce jeu a l'air normal
choisi si le nom que vous préférez donc
déjà chaque noix un prix apparemment on
a coeur millions donc on peut que saper
les dogues man voilà l'homme chien super
bienvenue sur normal adventures auquel
on met dans le village des doubles mais
qui nous met carrément confiance à sas
voyez ça c'est l'expérience voilà ça
s'appelle l'expérience de tous ces jeux
de merde qui on a en vrai je n'ai même
pas vu donc votre timing jeunes generico
salue donc manne bienvenue sur normal
aventure je vais maintenant dans le
village des nums le développeur
m'envoyait pour te protéger les plus
hauts des plus hauts niveaux que toi ah
ah ok d'accord amap est là pour protéger
ce one shot travers des villes des c'est
bon je pense qu'il faut y aller moi je
vais suivre les recrues un ânon taïzou
prévu le mec qui faisait cette blague
quoi ils ont dit non tu ne feras pas
c'est le black star tour bras voilà
j'aimerais tant faire comme vous attaque
défense escape attaque on est courageux
- hp
il va me faire quoi moins 10 milliards à
le mois 65 mais ça marche très bien et
skype
je propose de l'enfouir au oui/non up
non pourquoi je trouvais dans le trou
doivent dominer la non il nous a touché
les fesses hop ça c'est le skill aller
ouais on a passé le niveau est très bien
avec un qi de zéro ça me plaît beaucoup
à vous sentez leur mac ou pas le banc
dans le vide voilà très bien et des
poissons qui viennent du vide on se bat
pour quoi sceller steve bah oui on n'y
croyait pas on n'y croyait plus du moins
bienvenue monsieur chien vous êtes notre
sauveur a laissé ça mettez-vous à genoux
devant moi non six chanteurs sauveur
pourquoi tu me tues [ __ ] au nom allâh
le coup classique du tube invisible
merci beaucoup attendent les nuages
avant d'élire un truc avec les nuages
déjà c'est sûr et certain
oh ne s'agenouille pas exécuter cet
homme salut aux bâtards au lait s'est
pas mis à genoux il m'a tuer
tranquillement qua non moi j'aime ta
clame pas voilà je suis un peu se
tournent aujourd'hui
donc j'estime esquive les choses comme
ça [ __ ] il appelle son diplôme alors
faut sauter au-dessus for thought et
voilà allez il faut passer alors
oh mais non mais non mais cette arnaque
alors ici je vais dessus battant mais il
ya comme un piège dans ce cube quoi il
ya plus de pièges dans ce cube junger
games ont déconné aux prix ils font les
choses pareil [ __ ] c'est classique en
plus le pas du pillage originaux quoi à
un oui je parle à toi celui qui a
développé ce jeu parce que moi je suis
un peu emporté objets via notre direct
au fait le truc avancé moi je reste sur
place mais sérieusement on y va c'est
drôle mais ça c'est drôle je vais tout
faire tuer un dc3 minutes c'est la fin
ah vous êtes toujours pas mort c'est au
dessus ah oui mais non adams et laporte
qui a tué le plus de monde rôle or voilà
elle j'avais dit qu'il y avait un truc
avec les nuages avaient dit regret a
déjà cette bouche quoi on dirait déjà
qu'il est en train de faire un malaise
avant même qu'on qui nous touche ah je
sais peut-être je sais peut-être
ah ah ah je suis sûr que tu monde a eu
un petit espoir dans son écran 1 ou
alors sous le sol et alors ça compte
quand même médaille ça y est ça y est
les réflexes bizarre comment ce jeu
c'est à temps si j'appuie sur le panneau
la voilà fallait juste appuyé sur
l'apport [ __ ] donc apparemment j'ai
une carte c'est parti à l'est voilà des
bonnes m'a bourré de pièges comme on les
déteste
elle dégage est allé à moi je suis un
bon comment maintenant je pense qu'il
faut il faut que je coure vraiment ah
non voilà moi je lui fais un cadeau de
bienvenue saluée lui il n'en voulait pas
hélas non non non non c'est vrai rien
ainsi maintenant je peux sauter dessus
peut-être bien sûr que non
comment j'ai pu croire des choses
pareilles hop oui voilà ok c'est bon
fallait les éliminer par pièce je m'en
vais merci nuage et pas avoir tué voilà
pas de problème
attendez attendez attendez j'ai cru voir
qu'il soit intéressant voilà on peut le
déplacer non pourquoi tu ne suis pas
l'oublier sur quoi tu as marché avant
partie l aventure un jeune niveau 1
john numbi je sais pas quoi dire voilà
je pense pas que les nuages faisait des
choses pareilles non ouais voilà le coup
de mecs qui sont en même temps des djeun
esquivant de poupe
yeah ouais j'ai fait à l'américaine
puisque ça parce que il faut que je le
ramène quand shoot
non ils retourner de l'autre côté de la
map même plus loin il est retourné au
niveau 1 3 le morceau de terre moins
1000 de cuba ça va ce pas mal alors
est-ce que si je lui tape dessus ça se
peut appeler un abandon au volley ou
tomber telle est la question c'est un
flop birds mais non
j'aimais la musique de ce niveau par
contre voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai à
dire sur ce niveau se retrouve au
prochain salue on va y arriver
c'est obligatoire un jeune enfant aux
mèches grises on est pas mal là on est
pas mal à les supporter c'est le dernier
achèvement je peux voler 100% je peux
aller plus loin mais la planète
et c'est quoi cette aile [ __ ]
franchement regardez la gueule de
l'icône quoi vraiment il n'a pas pris la
belle ailes d'ange méga style et que
tout monde a envie d'avoir ce sont deux
au non non non il a pris la bonne ailes
de mouches bien dégueu que personne ne
veut non mais il doit encore y avoir un
truc à la con auquel on ne pense pas
parce que nous sommes des gens normaux
et humains atteint
oh non oh je déteste le mauvais temps
allez enfin après 128 minutes de jeu et
maintenant map 2 vous rendez vous compte
que tout le monde s'en bat les steaks a
alors déjà j'ai découvert un truc sans
faire exprès tu peux passer au dessus je
ne savais pas voilà au plat skis mon
gars non allez fils de chien et c'est la
mort au blé aux bâtards boss
non non à je sais pas trop maintenant il
nous reste un engrenage qui ferme la
porte
peut-être qu'ils cassent la porte en
fait quand ils passent tournée on va
tester hop et la casse on a cherché en
champion de la mort faire un fail plus
de 100 fois merci c'est probablement
l'achèvement le plus mignon que j'ai vu
de ma vie
ouais ça en fait des fois quand je râle
ça me gratte le cuir chevelu
voilà attendez je tiens à quelque chose
je tiens non non la la je tenais ma mort
tendez non mais c'est passé tu dois
remettre là à qui suit dans la bouche de
poissons attendez attendez attendez on
progresse on progresse l'enquète avance
voilà un peu le cas c'est [ __ ] mais du
coup j'ai pris tous ok c'est que ça a à
mahomet cheveux gris elle vient de
battre
hop là il y avait une bonne technique là
là vraiment c'est the expendables mais
sans les acteurs connus mais c'était pas
mal du coup la ya plus personne banon
banon tout le monde est rentré chez lui
bah oui c'est le soir il est tard qu'est
ce que c'est que ça mes horaires mais on
voit envoie son coup de canon regarder
l'eau je suis comme paralysé avec un
temps qu'un mais quand tu es allé dont
ben voilà téléporté dans le néant
s'ils jouent tijou effets spéciaux
incroyables y ait au moins au moyen d'un
coffre qui [ __ ] pourquoi il ya des
elle style et lui lui l'a pas les ailes
de mouches vous avez eu un artefact très
bien bavaud la deuxième map
allez on y va c'est quoi cette parodie
moisi de pvl watts
j'aimais à cochons je sais pas comment
j'ai fait ça mais j'ai mis un cochon
l'impression de faire la partie de
l'année sur le jeu de l'année
pas du tout qui sont ces gens et des
couronnes faut la vouloir dégager la
couronne non non maintenant à
or [ __ ] il va tuer le cochon quoi mais
non mais c'est n'importe quoi
mais j'essaie 130 pièces mon gars cela
fait un peu partout cent mille plants
sur la même ligne et bah oui très bien
un matin [ __ ] de jeux de poissons j'ai
jamais aimé la pêche aux poissons aux
quais à la fête foraine
bon c'était des canards mais bon très
bien ça très bien bravo c'est comme ça
que j'applaudis les gens que j'aime pas
non j'ai fait un retour ac les poissons
se manger entre arrêt sur images voici
des poissons mangent et d'autres
poissons qui appartiennent tous à la
même espèce j'ai un scientifique et
j'approuve pas du tout c'est faux
raccords [ __ ] jamais eu un bon feeling
je m'en vais m'en vais par la halle est
tombé par là ça fait même plus rire de
découvrir ça saute ont très bien aux
[ __ ] s'inverser flèche
j'ai compris le truc s'est inversée
flèche vous ne m'aurez pas à quelle est
cette colline quelle est cette colline
aux nomades
oh je vais mon année tient pendant qu'un
passant et la voilà qu'une colline
marche bon voilà on fait quelques
efforts mais on l'admet mais qu'une
colline saute
non ouais c'est parti c'est la map 2
j'aime pas du tous ces leviers est allé
tourner
oui suivant non il peut pas casser la
peau car je te tape dessus explose et
que le mot oh oh oh fallait sauter
dessus
ah les bombes non pourquoi tu m'aides et
puis tu es plus
je ne mourrai pas ce soir ce soir est à
nouveau soir ce soir est à nouveau ce
soir ce soir est un nouveau chanson
intitulée ce soir est un nouveau soir
voilà disponible sur itunes pour la
modique somme de 4 euros 90 ce qui me
servira à acheter une bouteille de vin
pour oublier que c'est moi le chanteur
cette piètre au champ gauche à notre
place c'est ce qu'on va voir bitches
brew o no boom et si le deuxième coffre
avec ses belles l&g l'artefact c'est le
retour de plants versus zombies parodie
cette fois c'est à des trucs cochons ça
va donner 0 pièce boîte à y renvoie les
goules
mais alors comment faire je vais déterré
toutes les plantes qui tire au moment où
ceux qui tournent arrive c'est ma
stratégie j'ai mis environ deux secondes
et demie à la voir c'est la vie tu
l'étais ration non non non trop tard le
poisson qui s'envole et qui fait un
double kill mon dieu c'est incroyable ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui dans des
chiffres des lettres dans pvz torodi la
peine
robert oui c'est moi allez c'est bon
j'en peux plus je rage quit bon ben
voilà j'en sais tout pour normand
l'adventure chez soi si vous aura plu
c'est le cas ne s'était pas aimé la
vidéo ça fait vraiment plaisir je suis
désolé mais là je ne peux pas continuer
sinon je risque l'avc mais vraiment on
sent toute évidence nouvelle bla bla bla
bla bla j'ai lu ça vous qui fumier de la
fumée là qui va sortir un jour je
dominerait ces jeux qui font rager tout
le monde voilà c'était le message eric
du jour 6 un peu plus
[Musique]